هي اول ظهور علنيا له منذ توجيه لائحه
الاتهام ضده على خلفيه اساءه التعامل مع
وثائق سريه سارع الرئيس السابق دعنو ترامب
الى نفي التهم واصفا اياها بانها تصيد
وملاحقه سياسيه من خصوم سياسيين فاسدين
كلام ترامبا جاء في مؤتمرين للحزب
الجمهوري في ولايتي جورجيا
اللتين تشكلان منطلقا لكل من يسعى للوصول
الى البيت الابيض
لم توجهتهم الى هيلاري كلينتون وذلك ما
كان يجب فعله غير ان الديمقراطيين قرروا
حمايتها والرئيس بايدن لم توجه اليه
اتهامات وانما فعله سيء جدا وفي المقابل
لا حديث لهم الا عني ولا يكيلون التهمه
الا اليه
خصومه
لنيلي لقب مرشح الحزب الجمهوري للرئاسه
هبوا للدفاع عنه حاكموا ولايه فلوريدا
الجمهوريه
هاجم ما جاء في لائحه الاتهام معتبرا ان
هناك كيلا بمكيالين في القضاء في حين دعا
مايك بانس نائب ترامب السابق والمرشح
الرئاسي الحالي وزير العدل لشرح سبب المضي
قدما في توجيه لائحه الاتهام
نلتقي في نورث كارولينا بعد يوم يحزن
وميريكا فالرئيس السابق يواجه لائحه اتهام
من وزاره عدل يديرها الرئيس الحالي
للولايات المتحده وخصم سياسي المحتمل
لكن بعض الجمهوريين مثل المرشح الرئاسي
كريستي اعتبر ان ما حملته لائحه الاتهام
يعد مدمرا في حين شدد الديمقراطيون وعلى
راسهم زعيم الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
شقشومر وزعيم الاقليه في مجلس النواب حكيم
جافريز على ان لا احد فوق القانون دعينا
ان صار ترامب ومنتقده الى السماح لهذه
القضيه بالمضي قدما بشكل سلمي في المحكمه
هذا في وقت تبرز اسئله حول مستقبل ترامب
السياسي
لا احد بامكانه الجزم بما يمثله توجيه
التهم لترشح ترامب او لحملته لاننا لم
نشهد سابقا امرا مماثلا هذه هي المره
الاولى التي نرى فيها مرشح المتهما في
قضيتين مختلفتين على الاقل
اللحظه يبدو ان تاييد اغلبيه الجمهوريين
الترامب لم يتاثر رغم توجيه تهم له مرتين
خلال ثلاثه اشهر لكن البعض هنا يخشى ورغم
رفضه التهمه من تاثير ذلك على مكانه ترامب
في حال فاز بولايه رئاسيه ثانيه بسبب